[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial
duel au sommaire aujourd'hui deux hommes
forts du continent sud-américain entre
la concurrence est rude et l'antagonisme
grandissant ce sont deux visions
politiques et économiques qui
s'affrontent mais aussi deux caractères
différents celui du brésilien jr bolton
arrow est de l'argentin alberto
fernandez
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici une brève
présentation de nos duellistes c'est le
blitz âgé de 61 ans et alberto fernandez
grandi à buenos aires avec sa mère et
son père adoptif qui est juge fédéral de
lui le jeune alberto hérite la passion
pour le droit il étudie à l'université
de buenos aires et obtient en 1983 son
diplôme d'avocat
durant ses études il rejoint d'abord le
parti nationaliste constitutionnel puis
change de cap et adhère au parti
justicialiste de quatre ans plus âgée
que son futur adversaire jaillir ball
sonar aux aînés dans l'état de sao paulo
dans une famille catholique de six
enfants
après ses études secondaires il choisit
sa carrière de militaire il entre dans
l'académie militaire d'agulla ce n'est
grâce et sert ensuite dans l'armée
brésilienne comme capitaine d'artillerie
en 1988 il devient militaire de réserve
au début de sa carrière professionnelle
fernandez en scène le droit et travaille
comme juges assesseurs son ascension
politique commence à partir de 1985
lorsqu'il le cube d'abord le poste de
sous directeur général des affaires
juridiques au ministère de l'économie
et puis il dirige la surintendance des
assurances l'organisme chargé de réguler
et surveiller les activités d'assurance
en argentine en 1998 il est l'un des
fondateurs du groupe
kalafat un feeling tincques au nom du
quai et l'appui d'abord la candidature
d'eduardo duhalde et à l'élection
présidentielle en 1999 et ensuite celle
de nestor kirchner en 2003 élu président
on espère tenir ses nerfs le nomme
premier ministre après l'arrivée au
pouvoir de cristina kirchner en 2007 il
démissionne à la suite d'un scandale lié
à la hausse des impôts sur les
exportations du soja ball sonar ou lui
entame sa carrière politique en tant que
conseiller municipal à rio et deux ans
plus tard il devient député du parlement
fédéral
à ce poste il se fait remarquer par sa
position ultra conservatrice il se
prononce en faveur de la peine de mort
de la légalisation du port d'armes et de
l'abaissement de l'âge de la
responsabilité pénale
fernandez quant à lui 2
y'a un critique virulent de cristina
kirchner après sa démission pourtant en
ils s'unissent de nouveau afin
d'empêcher un second mandat de mauricio
macri candidat de droite et comme
kirchner est mise en examen dans
plusieurs dossiers de corruption
fernandez devient le candidat de la
coalition
il fait sa campagne sur les promesse de
réformer l'économie du pays et à entamer
la lutte contre la pauvreté
le résultat de l'élection le donnent
vainqueur à ce moment-là jaillir ball
sonar occupe déjà le poste de président
sa route vers la présidence comme ans en
lorsqu'il est désigné candidat du parti
social libéral lors de sa campagne il
promet d' éradiquer la corruption et de
lancer en combat impitoyable contre la
criminalité
à l'issue du scrutin il obtient 55 % des
votes dans le second tour raciste
misogyne et homme violent dès le début
de sa campagne présidentielle
alberto fernandez ne cache pas son
antipathie envers jaillir ball sonar ou
en retour le président brésilien traite
fernandez de borderouge et soutient son
adversaire au scrutin présidentiel
une hostilité mutuelle qui découle
largement des différences idéologiques
alors que le président brésilien prône
une ligne politique ultra conservatrice
son homologue argentin de lui défend
plutôt une vision de gauche dit
péroniste économie environnement domaine
social et bien sûr diplomatie dès sa
prise de fonction fernandez fait un
virage socialiste et se rapproche du
mexique et de cuba
molson a role lui maintient la pression
sur le venezuela et se pose à l'
influence grandissante de mexico
surnommé le trump des tropiques un
raison de son admiration pour donald
trump le président brésilien se
rapproche davantage du président
américain d'alors
cependant la défaite de ce dernier fait
le jeu de fernandez qui tend la main à
l'administration de joe biden côté
économique la tension s'accroît aussi à
cause des divergences avec son homologue
argentin ball sonar aux menaces de
sortir du mercosur marché commun
réunissant plusieurs états de la région
alors
quelle est l'ampleur de la confrontation
actuelle entre les deux chefs d'état
comment leur antipathie personnelle
affecté les relations bilatérales et les
alliances politiques dans la région
quelles sont les perspectives des
relations argentine au brésil viennent
pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons carlos herrera professeur à
synergy paris universités spécialiste de
l'amérique latine monsieur rérat beaux
jours tout d'abord à l'arrivée au
pouvoir gerb au sonar ou a été surnommé
le donald trump des tropiques pensez
vous qu'il est justifié ce surnom
pendant ses années à la tête du brésil
oui je crois que assez largement
déjà il ya aussi solide archi à coups de
propos appelé outrancier on pourrait
dire même à l'ère dopé à la testostérone
exemple dans la défense corps d'armes ou
de propos misogynes tous à dessiner une
familiarité avec l'univers eux mais
c'est rare qu'ils sont plus déconseillés
commun comme style pannon donc il se
rapproche de ce qu'on appelait la droite
alternative
la halte rate parfois on parle de
populisme en france mais pas que le
concept est moins précis il faut dire
aussi que vaut le sauna au était connu
par delà les frontières de son pays
si vous vous souvenez quand en 2016 lors
de la procédure d'impeachment et la
présidente dilma rousseff
il avait lors de son vote révendiquer la
figure d'un tortionnaire militaire très
connu il est lui-même un ancien membre
des forces armées et captant au moment
d'abandonner les forces armées dans les
années 80 je dirais même que par
certains bien il peut apparaître comme
plus réducteur déjà il était mieux élu
donald trump
sartre lens en système qui tapait
différentes mais il y avait une autre
les carences en fonction de voir même 46
55 secondes et puis on peut le penser
que dans la démocratie nord américaine
il y avait tout de même des contre
pouvoirs plus importants de peu dans
celle du brésil
bien que l'a vu récemment avec
l'invasion capitole tout n'est pas
parfait
après il ya un dernier élément que je
cherche intéressés qu'aujourd'hui les
enquêtes d'opinion donnent mais si le
sauna au gagnant lors des prochaines
élections présidentielles en 2022
il a une cote de popularité qui reste
importante on verra si pouvoir la
maintenir dans le temps qui reste encore
pour la nouvelle élection
faut dire qu'au brésil à ce moment là la
gauche est assez divisés et que même si
la tuque est bien naturel du pt n'a pas
l'autorisation à ce moment alors
surveillez vos damnation oui oui oui
pourriez-vous nous décrire la
personnalité d'alberto fernandez qui est
moins connu du grand public
oui en fait il est à l'ombre d'un
caractère assez sobre on pourrait dire
vers un peu gris un dépit des efforts
qu'on a faits notamment lors de la
campagne électorale pour le montrer plus
moderne plus passionnés on a mis à
l'avance l'amour du football sur l'amour
de la guitare et du rock
puis il est marié avec une femme bien
plus jeune que lui
plutôt sexy mais lui-même il préfère
s'est présenté comme un juriste va tout
comme le juriste de droit pénal et ce
qui montre déjà une sorte de sobriété et
surtout il insiste beaucoup qui les
talons des dialogues qui linda langue de
compromis et d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est sur ce point
là qu'il reçoit à ce moment les
critiques de ce concours appelé labeouf
l'alliance qui l'a conduit au pouvoir
par exemple on lui a reproché il ya
quelques jours à peine
son sa réunion avec les principaux
représentants de producteurs agricoles
c'est une
c'était une charge symbolique importante
puisque il m'était adressé par
l'intelligent historique des mères de la
place d'emile ou avant et même
aujourd'hui parce qu'il se dit
dépression on lui reproche soirée j'ai
ça sort et fut plutôt le utiliser le
droit d grâce en faveur des certains
dirigeants du mouvement kirchneriste qui
sont en prison monsieur rérat merci
beaucoup nous allons poursuivre notre
analyse tout de suite et nous vous
retrouverons à la fin de cette émission
pour plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore autrefois solides l'amitié entre
le brésil et l'argentine se fissure
suite à l'arrivée au pouvoir de jaillir
ball sonar haut d'un côté et d'alberto
fernandez de l'autre en croire les
médias locaux depuis des décennies les
relations entre les deux états n'ont
jamais été aussi mauvaises ans les deux
plus grands états d'amérique latine le
brésil et l'argentine entretiennent des
relations de bon voisinage tout au long
du xxème siècle or un véritable
rapprochement commence après la chute
des dictatures militaires dans ces pays
au milieu des années 80 les nouvelles
autorités signe deux accords qui
devienne la pierre angulaire des
relations bilatérales
la déclaration d'iguaçu et celle de la
politique nucléaire
si cette dernière porte uniquement sur
la coopération dans le domaine nucléaire
la déclaration dit quoi sous renforce
les liens dans plusieurs domaines
économie commerce transport
communication sciences technologies et
énergies
depuis 1997 la coopération bilatérale
prend la forme d'une alliance
stratégique
les deux états tiennent désormais des
rencontres régulières en matière de
défense et de sécurité
les relations bilatérales sont au beau
fixe pendant la présidence de nestor
kirchner en argentine et lula da silva
au brésil ardent défenseur des idées de
gauche
il signe une série d'accords bilatéraux
en forçant la coopération dans quasi
tous les domaines une tendance qui
continue avec les successeurs de
kirchner et da silva
l'arrivée au pouvoir des conservateurs
de droite mauricio macri en argentine et
jacques bolle sonar ou au brésil ne
change pas grand chose
en quelques mois seulement ce tandem
tient plusieurs rencontres et songe à
l'introduction d'une monnaie commune
le peso real pourtant l'amitié brésilo
argentine se fissure après l'élection en
argentine du candidats péronistes
alberto fernandez pour la première fois
bolcho narrow et fernandel s'affrontent
durant la campagne présidentielle en
argentine après la victoire de fernandez
aux primaires considérée comme une
répétition générale avant l'élection
présidentielle le président brésilien
hausse le ton envers le candidat de
gauche
si cette gauche pour y revient au
pouvoir en argentine
nous pourrions avoir une nouvelle crise
de réfugiés dans le sud du brésil
la réponse de fernandez ne s'est pas
fait attendre maintenant en termes
politiques
je n'ai rien à voir avec bolton araud je
me réjouis grandement qu'il dise du mal
de moi c'est un raciste un misogyne un
homme violent
un antagonisme personnel qui est le
fruit de deux visions politiques
opposées ultra libéral sur le plan
économique très conservateur sur le plan
politique creillois sonar au ne cache
pas son hostilité pour l'idéologie de
gauche et les personnalités politiques
et la représente cristina kirchner
dilma rousseff nicolás maduro encore
fidel castro ball sonar au les qualifie
tous deux bandits
lors de la campagne présidentielle
argentine et les affiche ouvertement son
soutien au candidat de la droite
argentine
mauricio macri son adversaire de gauche
alberto fernandez se bat dès le début de
sa campagne pour la libération de lula
da silva
bête noire de bruce sohn a roué
président socialiste brésilien en
juillet 2019 il lui rend visite dans la
prison brésilienne tout en émettant des
critiques sur le système juridique du
brésil après la victoire de fernandez le
président brésilien refuse
catégoriquement de féliciter le
président élu est d'assister à la
cérémonie de son investiture
une première depuis des décennies une
antipathie personnelle qui se déverse
même sur les familles des deux
dirigeants tout commence par une
publication d'eduardo ball sonar hall e
fils du président brésilien il re
tweetent une photo de lui même et du
fils de fernandez estanislao ce dernier
est un tenue de cosplay pikachu eduardo
lui tient un fusil
estanislao évite de répondre directement
à eduardo mais s'adresse via son compte
twitter à la communauté lgbt brésilienne
l'appelant à poursuivre la lutte pour
leurs droits
la tension entre les deux dirigeants
franchi une nouvelle étape avec le début
de la pandémie alors que fernandez
impose un confinement nationale ball
sonar au s'oppose à toutes les mesures
de restriction qui pourrait selon lui
mettre à genoux l'économie brésilienne
il pointe alors du doigt l'argentine où
la crise économique s'est amplifiée
fernandez lui qualifie de dangereuse la
proche de son homologue brésilien
preuve à l'appui le brésil reste le pays
le plus frappé par le corona virus en
amérique latine avec près de 10 millions
de cas détectés
il aura fallu que le dirigeant brésilien
contracte lui même le virus pour qu'un
signe d'apaisement voit le jour la
lettre de fernandez dans laquelle il
souhaite un bon rétablissement à bolton
araud a eu un effet bénéfique
quelques mois plus tard les deux
antagonistes entament le dialogue direct
le 30 novembre une rencontre par visio
conférence a lieu lors de cet échange
qui dure environ 40 minutes alberto
fernandez appelle son homologue à
surmonter les difficultés du passé
molson arrow parle plutôt du
renforcement de la coopération
économique et militaire entre les deux
pays sans toutefois aborder la question
de la normalisation politique
un rapprochement ont un effet d'annonce
nos deux duellistes ont des points de
vue trop différent dans quasiment tous
les domaines
sur le plan économique gr ball ce
barreau est partisan d'une approche
libérale
il prône la privatisation et défend
l'idée du libre échange
fernandez lui est favorable au contrôle
de la devise et à des mesures
protectionnistes
farouche défenseur de l'environnement le
président argentin appel à un plus grand
engagement des pays développés pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
de son côté jacques bolson arrow est un
climato sceptiques convaincus
il encourage le développement de
l'agriculture et de l'élevage en
amazonie et couple financement de l'
agence nationale de protection de
l'environnement
sur le plan social les positions ne sont
pas non plus du tout les mêmes hole sun
araw étant à un détracteur de
l'avortement et du mariage homosexuel
alberto fernandez lui défend les droits
de la communauté lgbt et salue
l'adoption récente de la loi autorisant
l'avortement
comment les deux dirigeants s'affrontent
il sur l'échiquier régional comment
cette antipathie personnelle affecte
tels les relations économiques entre le
brésil et l'argentine
comment l'arrivée de joe biden à la
maison blanche peut-elle influencer le
rapport de force dans ce duel
la réponse après la pause le
conservateur contre le péroniste
l'opposition idéologique de nos
duellistes laisse sa marque sur les
relations régionales de leur pays avant
de passer au détail rappel des faits
après la chute de la dictature en
argentine et au brésil
les deux états maintiennent en cap
similaire à l'international il se
rapproche de l'uruguay et du pérou
deux autres états ayant mis fin au
régime militaire et lance le processus
d'intégration régionale
c'est à ce moment que voit le jour le
groupe de rio organisation visant à
améliorer la coopération entre les
différents pays d'amérique latine et le
marché commun du sud mercosur
initié par le brésil l'argentine
l'uruguay et le paraguay
à la différence du brésil l'argentine
entretient une relation particulière
avec washington qu'elle soutient dans
quasi toutes ces démarches à
l'international un partenariat qui finit
avec l'arrivée au pouvoir de nestor
kirchner péroniste conjointement avec
son homologue brésilien lula da silva
il signe le consensus de buenos aires s
doctrine visant à contrer le
néolibéralisme en amérique latine les
deux plus grands états régionaux font un
virage à gauche en se rapprochant du
venezuela de hugo chavez du chili de
ricardo lagos du cuba de fidel castro de
la bolivie d'evo morales avec l'arrivée
au pouvoir de mauricio macri en
argentine le cap international argentin
change nous
fois conservateur de droite il se
distancie des anciens alliés gauchistes
et se rapproche des présidents de droite
chilien sebastian pinera et colombien
ivan bouquet l'élection de gerbes aux
sonars ou au brésil amplifie la cadence
il est l'un des rares chefs d'état a
salué le coup d'état en bolivie et à
soutenir l'embargo américain de cuba le
brésil et l'argentine semble regarder
dans la même direction et cela jusqu'à
l'élection d'alberto fernandez en
argentine fidèle à la ligne de son allié
donald trump ball sonar au maintient la
pression sur nicholas maduro
il est à l'avant-garde du groupe de lima
qui réunit la plupart des pays latino
américains et soutient juan wade au
président vénézuélien autoproclamé sous
l'ex président mauricio macri et
l'argentine a rejoint ce groupe
cependant alberto fernandez
idéologiquement proche du chavisme
vénézuélien change de cours pendant sa
campagne électorale et promet même de
quitter le groupe de lima pour l'instant
la promesse n'est pas tenue mais
al'inverse de bol sonar ou fernandez
refuse de critiquer maduro directement
au venezuela il n'y a pas de dictature
mais un gouvernement autoritaire les
dictatures ont des origines
antidémocratique
mais ce n'est pas le cas du venezuela
quant au reste du continent les deux
visions diffèrent là aussi j'ai ri bosso
narrow assure ne même pas connaître le
nom du chef d'état cubain actuelle
miguel diaz cannelle alberto fernandez
lui fait de la rencontre avec le cubain
son premier acte officiel en tant que
président et sa première visite
officielle à l'étranger est au mexique
dirigé par un autre leader de gauche
entre temps le brésil de bol sonar au
tente de contrer l'influencé gauchistes
de mexico dans l'amérique centrale et
courtise le guatemala et le honduras
parallèlement brasilia suspend sa
participation dans le bloc économique
régional ces lacs au moment même où le
mexique assume sa présidence
ne donnez pas une chance à la gauche il
ne mérite pas d'être traités comme des
gens normaux qui veulent le bien du
brésil cette maudite gauche n'a marché
nulle part dans le monde en dehors du
continent latino-américain le jeu des
alliances entre nos deux duellistes ne
reste pas figée non plus pour bonnart au
la balance des forces peu changé avec le
départ de son grand ami donald trump la
relation du brésilien avec joe biden est
déjà mal parties pendant la campagne
présidentielle américaine les deux se
sont querellés par médias interposés au
sujet des feux de forêt en amazonie
molson arrow assure que l'élection
américaine était truquée et de félicite
le démocrate que mi-décembre
l'argentin lui est plus proche de bail
donne sur le climat et d'autres enjeux
il saisit le moment pour se présenter un
principal allié américain dans la région
ainsi fernandez est le premier dirigeant
latino américain a félicité by donne
pour son élection et le dialogue se
poursuit depuis cette poussée de
fernandez vistelle à isoler son rival
pas seulement la bienveillance
américaine est cruciale pour l'argentine
au moment où elle négocié un plan de
sauvetage avec le fmi avant d'examiner
le côté économique de ce duel
faisons le récap les deux plus grandes
économies d'amérique du sud le brésil et
l'argentine entretiennent d'étroites
relations commerciales depuis des
décennies
actuellement l'argentine est le
quatrième partenaire commercial du
brésil et le brésil le premier de
l'argentine leurs échanges commerciaux
atteignent actuellement plusieurs
dizaines de milliards de dollars et ce
principalement grâce à la coopération
étroite au sein du mercosur
créée en 1991 cette organisation est
faste en effet les barrières
commerciales entre plusieurs états
d'amérique du sud
or mercosur les deux états renforce
d'année en année leurs liens commerciaux
avec la chine et l'union européenne qui
sont placés parmi leurs principaux
partenaires économiques
aujourd'hui pourtant l'avenir des
relations économiques entre le brésil et
l'argentine reste ambigu après l'arrivée
au pouvoir de gerbes aux sonars ou au
brésil et d'alberto fernandez en
argentine
souhaitant relancer le développement de
la production nationale ce dernier prône
une politique économique protectionniste
alors que le président brésilien défend
avec ardeur la libéralisation du marché
commun fernandez protectionnistes
bessonart au néo libérale la
confrontation de deux visions
économiques laisse sa marque sur leurs
liens commerciaux
en 2020 le volume des échanges
bilatéraux chute de plus de 20% par
rapport à 2019 selon brasilia s'est
buenos aires qui freine les échanges et
retarde l'octroi des licences pour les
produits brésiliens
résultat les marchandises brésilienne
reste bloquée pendant des mois à la
frontière argentine une violation des
règles de l'om c'est aux yeux des
brésiliens ces tensions se répercutent
inévitablement sur l'activité du
mercosur
conscients de leur différence bolcho
narrow passe à l'attaqué avant même que
son rival ne soit élu président et
n'hésite pas à faire pression ce que
nous souhaitons c'est que l'argentine
poursuivre les politiques commerciales
de may cry en cas de victoire de
l'opposition
sinon nous pourrions discuter avec le
paraguay et l'uruguay pour prendre une
décision
malgré les divergences et les menaces de
bol sonar au l'avenir commun au sein du
mercosur est au centre de la première
conversation des dirigeants fin novembre
je me félicite de cette rencontre qui
donnera au maire qoussour l'impulsion
nécessaire et il est extrêmement
important que le brésil et l'argentine
le faste ensemble en effet sauver
l'accord de libre-échange union
européenne mercosur est le front commun
du brésil et de l'argentine qui
dépassent leurs divergences au niveau
bilatéral conclu en juin 2019
il n'est toujours pas ratifiée par
l'union européenne car le même été le du
monde se tourne vers les terrifiants
feux de forêt au brésil
les images font l'effet d'un choc en
europe emmanuel macron prend
l'initiative d'attaquer jaillir le bol
sonar au directement si sa politique
forestière ne change pas paris menacent
de mettre son veto sur l'accord ue
mercosur
pour y voir plus clair nous revenons
vers carlos herrera professeur à siwa et
cergy paris universités spécialiste de
l'amérique latine monsieur rérat parlons
maintenant de l'aspect géopolitique de
ce duel pensez vous
que l'arrivée de joe biden renforcera
les positions de l'argentine sur
l'échiquier régional au contraire
affaiblira les positions de bol sonar ou
bien je ne suis pas certain c'est un
sujet complexe le déjà il faut dire que
le brésil a été historiquement l'allié
des etats-unis dans la région à l'allier
plus sûr et l'argentine
l'argentine avait toujours alimenté
depuis la fin du 19e et 20e siècles nous
ford est méfiant des concurrences même
pour le leadership dans la région
l'argentine échangera d'opinion que au
début des années 1990 avec l'arrivée au
pouvoir d'un autre président péroniste
mais cnm donc ça c'est un élément déjà
qu'il faut en deux rencontres
parce que parfois les intérêts vont
dassa new direction inverse que les
positions idéologiques souvenez vous par
exemple j'ai vraiment encore dans le
temps que la dictature militaire
argentine n'avait pas suivi les
etats-unis qui avaient décrété l'embargo
commercial envers l'ancienne union
soviétique à la fin de 1979 dans la
dictature militaire argentine et des
anti communiste mais effectivement il ya
parfois des éléments qui vont orner la
laisse éventuel affinités idéologiques
qui peuvent exister entre biden et d'un
effet rebond texte est je dirais lol qui
a quelque chose qui va rendre plus
complexe l'analyse c'est à dire que dans
ce rapport entre les etats unis le
brésil et l'argentine
il ya un quatrième acteur je dirais que
la chine inquiète beaucoup à ce moment
même les états unis notamment pour ce
qui est de la présence chinoise est
négatif or il se trouve que bien que la
chine est devenue à marché principal
pour le brésil il se trouve que c'est en
argentine où la chine a fait la plupart
des investissements des ces quinze
dernières années au calcul selon des
études récentes que entre 2005 et 2010 9
39% à peu près de la bastille ce membre
infrastructure est allé en argentine et
il y a quelques semaines il ya eu un
petit incident avec un bateau de la
garde côtière nord américain que les
stones qui peinait à mission
l'atlantique sud pour contrôler
notamment la pêche illégale
souvent la chine etc petit incident
entre l'argentine et les états unis
c'est à dire que le bateau n'avait pas
accoster finalement dans le port
argentin prévenu il n'y avait pas eu
d'exercices communs comme il y en avait
eu au brésil
auparavant a été interprétée notamment
par la presse d'opposition comme un
signe de ces difficultés éventuelles qui
peuvent avoir des rapports entre
l'argentine et les états unis à cause de
la chine
après il est vrai que ne fait que messi
trappe n'est plus la maison blanche bas
à conduire mais si bolt you know à être
plus de sobriété sur certaines positions
comme du changement climatique
israël où il était certain de retrouver
une sorte de delko d'art ou fortement
des parapluies qu'il est protégé dans
les lieder et puis contrainte quand il
était la maison blanche une rivalité qui
est bien plus complexe donc oui merci
beaucoup monsieur herrera je rappelle
vous êtes professeur à six miles cergy
paris universités spécialiste de
l'amérique latine je rappelle carlos
herrera était là aujourd'hui avec nous
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]